♪ ♪ BAD NEWS FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
REOPENED THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE'S
USE OF A PRIVATE EMAIL SERVER,
SOMETHING PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
INVESTIGATING.
JUDICIAL WATCH FOUND OUT 18
CLASSIFY EMAILS WERE FOUND ON
ANTHONY WEINER'S LAPTOP.
HE'S THE HUSBAND OF HILLARY'S
TOP AIDE HUMA ABEDIN.
REASON TO DIG BACK IN?
>> Greg: I FEEL BAD FOR EVERY
INVESTIGATOR WHO NEEDS TO HANDLE
ANTHONY WEINER'S LAPTOP.
GOD KNOWS WHAT'S BEEN ON THERE.
CHEMICALS TO SPRAY IT DOWN.
THE GUYS COME IN HAZMAT SUITS.
THEY HAVE TONGS.
>> Kimberly: LIKE CSI TONGS.
>> Greg: A VAT OF ACID.
>> Kimberly: BLACKLIGHT.
THIS ISN'T A PROFESSIONAL SHOW.
>> Greg: ANYBODY IN THE LOWER
OFFICE WOULD BE GETTING THREE
HOTS AND A COT.
PRISON, NOT DR. SEUSS.
SENSE THAT IT'S LIKE TRUMP IS
LIKE A DOG THAT ALREADY CAUGHT
THE CAR AND KEPT RUNNING.
STILL WANTS TO DO THIS.
>> Jesse: HE WASN'T GOING TO
DO IT WHEN HE WAS ELECTED.
HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO LET
BYGONES BE BYGONES.
NOW THAT HE'S BEEN ATTACKED COME
HE'S GOING TO TURN THE HEAT UP
ON THE LEFT.
>> Dana: IT WILL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE IF THE DOJ IS
REALLY DOING ANYTHING.
THIS IS AN ANONYMOUS STORY
LEAKED TO "THE DAILY BEAST."
YOU HAVE A STORY SAYING ONE
REPUBLICAN LEANING STRATEGIST
SAYING THIS MAKES SENSE BECAUSE
HE WOULD HAVE FINALLY SOME
NONPARTISAN PEOPLE, OBJECTIVE
PEOPLE LOOK AT HER EMAIL
SITUATION.
THEN YOU HAVE GIVING BULGES THE
WHITE HOUSE -- YOU HAVE THE
OTHER THING, THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTINUES TO AGITATE.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK JEFF
SESSIONS HAS BEEN BROWBEATEN BY
THE PRESIDENT ON TWITTER?
>> Kimberly: POOR THING.
YOU GO WHERE JUSTICE LEADS YOU.
HE SHOULD BE DOING AN
INVESTIGATION IF NEW EVIDENCE
HAS COME TO LIGHT.
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO GO
FORWARD AND EXAMINE IT.
GIVE A FULL, FAIR, IMPARTIAL
EVALUATION.
BY THE WAY, IF NEW EVIDENCE --
FINE.
IF NEW EVIDENCE COMES TO LIGHT,
WHY WOULDN'T YOU?
>> Geraldo: GET OVER IT.
>> Kimberly: GET OVER WHAT?
>> Geraldo: IS THERE ONE
SCINTILLA OF EVIDENCE THAT
SUGGESTS THE RUSSIANS GOT ANY
INTELLIGENCE FROM
HILLARY CLINTON'S PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER?
YOU ALREADY RUINS THE CAREER OF
TREY GOWDY.
>> Kimberly: JASON CHAFFETZ
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU.
>> Geraldo: SO OLD, SO STAY
OLD, SO POINTLESS.
>> Greg: THAT IS MY POINT
ABOUT THE CONSISTENCY.
YOU WON THE ELECTION, YOU LET IT
GO.
BY NOT LETTING IT GO, IT SHOWS
YOU ARE MORAL.
>> Kimberly: WHEN YOU SHINE A
LIGHT ON SOMEONE, YOU ARE NOT
RUINING SOMEONE'S CAREER.
JASON CHAFFETZ SAT IN JESSE'S
SEAT.
>> Geraldo: WHAT'S THE BIG
HEADLINE?
THERE WAS SOME GUY THAT SERVICED
HER PRIVATE COMPUTER THAT MISLED
THEY GIVING IMMUNITY INSTEAD.
SO HE'S GOT IMMUNITY.
WHERE DOES IT GO?
HE GOES NO PLACE.
THIS IS A WASTE OF TIME AND IT
DISTRACTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
MAKES THEM LOOK LIKE LACKEYS.
MAKES SESSIONS LOOK LIKE KATE
McKINNON ON SATURDAY I'VE
JUMPING OUT OF THE CLOSET
SITTING ON TRUMP'S LAP.
HILLARY'S EMAIL.
I'M SO SICK OF IT.
IT IS LIKE BENGHAZI IN THE SENSE
THAT THERE'S NOTHING THERE.
MOVE ON.
GO AFTER THE DEMOCRATS ON
SOMETHING.
>> Kimberly: WE ARE ALL IN ON
BENGHAZI.
>> Greg: WHEN THEY BLAMED
BENGHAZI ON A VIDEO, THAT WAS A
PRETTY BIG LIE.
>> Kimberly: AND PUT THE GUY
IN JAIL.
HE >> Geraldo: THE FIRST
MILLION TIMES I WAS WITH YOU.
ADMITTED.
HILLARY LIVED OFF THAT LIE.
>> Geraldo: YOU HAVE THE